retard donc du coup ilque il manque mon
collègue ah ben voilà arrive voilà AR
alors
euh bonjour bonjour monsieur euh en
réitérant no nos excuses pour ces
difficultés
techniques inaugural on va
euh procéder à cette audition merciant
de votre disponibilité je vais commencer
par vous faire euh euh prêter serment
vous avez que le le formalisme lié à une
commission d'enquête nous impose
cette cette prestation de serment donc
je vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant la commission d'enquête serait
pas possible des peines prévu aux
article 434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code
pénal et je vais vous inviter l'un et
l'autre à prêter serment à dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité à lever la
main droite à dire je le
jure je le jure je le jure merci
beaucoup messieurs ce que je vous
propose
pour non pas rattraper le temps perdu
mais pour pour aller vite c'est que vous
avez reçu un questionnaire qui oriente
un certain nombre d'informations que que
cette commission souhaite recueillir et
avec Étienne blanc et l'ensemble des
élus qui sont présents aujourd'hui don
marie-lur finera h sénatrice de
guyan ben on vous propose de de de
commencer peut-être d'avoir un propos
liminaire et puis on vous pose des
questions ensuite ça vous
va très bien parfait pour
moi alors propos très court en tout cas
merci pour pour ce questionnaire c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet quand même
prignant préoccupant euh pour la guyen
donc on regarde peut-être regarde la la
configuration de notre population avec
53 % de personnes qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté donc avec un fort tau
de chômage euh donc les n les
narcotrafiquants ont toutes leur place
entre guillemets en Guyane donc pas donc
moi je serais ravi vraiment de
collaborer avec vous sur sur ce
dispositif sur ce ce rapport et en
espérant que ce sera pas pas unème
rapport mais vraiment un rapport qui
puisse apporter des solutions pérennes
visant à prévenir et réinsérer euh les
personnes qui qui veulent s'en s'en
sortir
aussi voà merci Monsieur labrador
oui mais écoutez-moi euh je pour
réitérer ce que je viens de dire mon
collègue Michel Jérémy à la différence
que moi j'ai été fonctionnaire de police
pendant 30 ans donc j'ai participé à un
peu à la lutte contre euh
malheureusement ce produit euh également
président de la Ligue de football on a
eu à connaître des footballeur
sanctionné en sélection pour avoir
utilisé les stupéfiant donc écoutez je
suis disposé à porter ce que je peux
porter
euh sur sur le sujet euh on espérant
effectivement que ce sera ça portera ce
fruit parce que visiblement notre
société est partie comme étant je veux
dire une une certaine logique en fait
d'utiliser le suupéfiant pour pouvoir
mieux comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
vie ou en tout cas pour mieux supporter
en tout cas le plus souvent en des
entretiens avec des jeunes euh qui sont
passés par là ou ce qui sont pas passés
par là ils vous disent monsieur vous
avez des copains euh bah ils se sonent
bien apr il dit ou mais ça les résultat
tu les retrouves après au bord de la
rue très bien merci voilà merci pour ces
interventions liminaires on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet et vous êtes tous
les deux élus locaux vous avez une
certaine ancienneté dans les fonctions
que vous exercez comment est-ce que vous
jugez aujourd'hui l'évolution du
narcotrafic en Guyane pour la population
locale pour les habitants de vos villes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
précisions sur les constats que vous
avez pu faire euh n notamment vous
monsieur labrador sur l'évolution des
conséquences négatives de ce trafic et
depuis que vous avez commencé exercz vos
mandats et le plus que vous avez une
activité professionnelle dans ce
domaine bien écoutez euh je ne vous
cache pas que
j'ai toujours pas compris
euh l'évolution en fait du du trafic
chez nous par rapport aux mesures de
de de répression qui pourrait être prise
lorsque je vois que le Surinam a mis son
détecteur a dispositif en place et nous
avons en fait hérité euh B tous ces
trafiquants qui viennent chez nous euh
la mise en place d'un système où vous
avez des gens qui sortent de métropole
et qui
viennent provisionner en tout cas faire
le trafic pour partir
dans en métropole dans l'xagone euh des
villes comme la ville du man je sais
qu'on a pas mal de jeunes là-bas qui bah
qui qui se sont installé dans dans le
trafic il a encore une autre ville mais
ça ça m'échappe donc je donner pas le
nom pour ne pas être dans le faux
euh bon c'est vrai qu' qu'il y a eu des
mesures qui prisent mais il y a
peut-être encore à faire pour bloquer le
système même le même système de
détection que la que la que que que le
Surinam peut-être que là
euh je dis pas qu'on trouvera la
solution mais en tout cas le le départ
euh sera difficile parce que la
procédure aussi sur le plan pénal elle
peut-être trop longue trop longue parce
que moi j'ai assuré également la garde
de de De Mul euh donc il y a à
l'extraction il y a surveillance à
l'hôpital il y a la procédure pénale euh
c'est-à-dire que euh à l'aéroport je
quand quand je passe je me dis que
maises mes collègues ils ont je suis en
encore comme tel après 15 ans de
retraite euh encore du du pain sur la
planche et je dira à la limite que le
principe même de soulagement de
d'allègement de la procédure n'a pas
évolué donc euh je crois que les les
trafiquants ils sent dessus sachant
forcément il y en a qui vont passer et
ils se basent pour eux dès le départ il
ils savent qu'il y a il y a une il y a
un taux de perte prévu pour eux dans
leur calcul et ce qui fait que il savent
qu'il vont récupérer ça
après moi je pense que c'est une des
raisons euh pour lesquelles sans doute
que on a cro pas n'arrivons pas à à à
réduire en tout cas le trafic et a plus
intensifier que
de de deux observations la première vous
dites le Suriname est plus performant
que nous donc ça entraîne un report sur
la Guyane premièrement et deuxièmement
vous dites quand on a réussi à
identifier à appréander les trafiquants
et nos procédures sont trop lourdes et
sont trop complexes ça prend beaucoup de
temps il y a il y a il y a du fait de se
temps consacré à la procédure elle-même
il y a une perte d'efficacité de nos
services je résume ce que vous venez de
nous
dire non mais je crois que j'y crois
fortement sans condamner parce que sais
que bon il y a CH a son système mais
comment expliquez-vous que vous avez des
gens qui viennent de métropole qui vont
Surinam s'alimenter alors que ils
reviennent sur la guyan pour pouvoir
pour partir avec tenter de partir avec
le produit alors qu'ils peuvent par le
surenam monter sur Amsterdam et rentrer
en France
après donc je crois que là-dessus
il y a
euh la la je pense que le les les
trafiquants ont pris en compte le le
taux de de perte de produits eu dans
dans leur trafic moi je je je connais un
un un je pas un trafiquant à l'époque je
pensais queétait un un GAB bien il était
à son 5e voyage et euh il était traité
normalement il a été en prison quand il
a été pris pour lors du 5e voyage quand
il a reessort de prison il avait une
voiture neuve qu'il attendait ça veut
dire que les gars il il apat
euh leur pro avec
euh quelque chose qui leur permettra à
la sortie euh ils sont pas malheureux
quoi quand vous voyez quand moi je vois
je travaille à la PAF quand vous arrêtez
quelqu'un qui fait un trafic de de
drogue le gars vous n'avez pas encore
entamé la procédure que vous avez un
avocat qui vous appelle c'est moi qui
assure la défense
d'El des fois c'est pas des moindres
c'est pas des moindres on même pas
encore le temps d'appeler un avocat que
le garoc qui appelle pour lui ça veut
dire que le système est très bien
organisé comment est-ce que vous évaluez
quel jugement portez-vous sur la
coopération entre la police la
gendarmerie les douanes différents
services en charge de lutte contre les
narcotrafic
très bonne moi je pense que c'est plutôt
notre système qui
devrait à mon avis qui devrait améliorer
pour soulager un petit peu pour rendre
plus performant les liens qu'il y a
entre entre ces différents
services sur les moyens techniques mis à
disposition de nos services et notamment
sur les scanners quel jugement
portez-vous écoutez je pense que est-ce
que je pense pas être dans le vrai mais
je crois quand même que si on mettait le
système de détection du Surin peut-être
on freinerait le le trafic en tout cas
on le rendrait beaucoup plus
difficile
hélas tout est reporté sur nous tout est
reporté sur
nous très
bien tout à l'heure vous avez cité un ex
exemple d'une personne qui a été
appréhendée a purgé sa peine et qui au
sortir de la détention a pu faire
l'acquisition d'une voiture et vivre
alors même sans doute j'imagine que ces
moyens ses
rémunération sa fortune personnelle ne
permet pas de vivre le train de vie
qu'elle affiche une fois qu'elle a purgé
sa
peine est-ce que selon vous et ça en
tant que maère vous pouvez l'identifier
par parce que vous êtes proche de votre
population est-ce que selon vous c'est
un véritable sujet le fait que
aujourd'hui on vit du trafic qu'on a un
train de vie qui est sans commune mesure
avec les rémunérations que l'on affiche
et est-ce que c'est un sujet et quel est
selon vous le moyen de remédier à cela
renforcement des contrôles sur le
patrimoine renforcement des contrôles
sur les comptes bancaires renforcément
des contrôles sur le train de vie
et ma question est-ce que vous avez
identifier cela comme un véritable sujet
en Guyane est-ce que vous avez des
suggestions pour qu'on puisse lutter
contre ces trafics
financiers écoutez c'est vous savez
c'est alors moi le le le métier je
connais euh euh mais c'est pas c'est pas
il y a qu'à faut compte parce que je
crois que c'est devenu de plus en plus
difficile de plus en plus difficile
euh parce que je vous cache pas que sur
ma commune euh je sais qu'il y a des
gars qui qui qui qui font le trafic
là-dessus les gens d' passent ils font
des fois des des contrôles inopinés bon
mais malheureusement le produit il est
caché des fois des côté dans des lieux
Bénin quoi je veux dire et une fois que
le contrôle est passé bon après les gars
continue le business c'est est-ce qu'il
faut mettre ça sur sur la faut des
moyens qui sont m à disposition je je je
ne sais pas moi je mais c'est vrai que
euh ça devient très inquiétant ça
devient très inquiétant alors il faut
voir peut-être dans dans la rédemption
je dirais voir comment on
peut faire plus de prévention à
l'école à la base sans doute
euh je pense que euh ça peut être
un un moyen aussi un moyen de prévention
parce que euh pas plus tard qu'hier soir
je regardais un un reportage euh dans
une commune euh c'était sur TF1 il me
semble
euh où il y a quand même une des
policiers ont quitté leur service pour
rentrer dans une société anonyme pour il
faisait de un peu de prévention en tout
cas dans dans dans le quartier de de
métropole je crois c'est à Toulouse il
me semble c'est peut-être au mirage dans
les mirages je crois
euh j'ai trouvé ça pas mal j'ai trouvé
ça pas mal mais je pense honnêtement que
cette prévention je ne sais pas si ça
existe à l'école devrait d dès le départ
dès le départ à la base rentrer dans
dans la formation dans l'initiation la
sensibilisation euh à l'école bon on a
malheureusement enlevé la de morale
c'est peut-être aussi une occasion là
aussi pourquoi pas et puis euh
euh sincèrement euh faire en sorte que
l'enfant soit sensibilisé et lui montrer
des images euh de ceux qui ont consommé
bon après on peut les fouter les images
mais il y a une certaine réalité des
choses parce que les enfants sont quand
même sensibles
euh qu au l'ormon certaines images
certaines réalités parce que moi je suis
également chargé de mission sécurité
routière je ne vous cache pas que
lorsque nous avions des images à montrer
euh des gens qui ont eu un accident et
que des personnes ont fait des photos et
bien on est obligé de mettre avec nous
une psychologue euh de façon à pouvoir
rattraper le coup lorsque les gens ont
vu les images al peut-être qu'il faudit
intensifier cette sensilisation à
l'école mais en ne falsifiant pas la
réalité des
choses est-ce que la Guyane est-ce que
vos communes sont frappées est-ce que
vous avez identifié des phénomènes de
corruption un développement de la
corruption du fait des masses
financières très importantes qui
circulent corruption dans les services
administratifs des collectivités
territoriales corruption dans les
services de l'État corruption de manière
généralisée est-ce que c'est un suet et
que vous avez identifié est-ce que vous
pouvez faire quelques constats
euh je dirais que non parce que quand je
le sais c'est parce que la presse en a
parlé ça veut dire que c'est déjà c'est
déjà sur la place publique je veux dire
non je je je ne connais pas de situation
sinon l'information reçue
euh reçu euh par par les médias même
quand j'étais en fonction parce que
j'étais motard dans dans la la police
euh bon on a fait quelques affaires avec
des collègues de la PJ mais je veux dire
que euh on a bon apprend on apprend
qu'il y a des affaires et cetera mais je
ne crois pas que Onon a eu temps que ça
de mémoire alors ces affaires elles
concernent des services de l'État ou les
collectivités territoriales euh non
c'était des affaires privées il me
semble
merci alors je vais proposer à nos
collègues ici
en en salle mdicise de poser des
question j'ai Monsieur Madame Boyer
d'abord désolé merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Monsieur le
Maire permettez-moi de vous poser deux
questions vous avez dit que c'était très
intéressant de montrer des images de aux
enfants à l'école et tout de suite vous
avez dit qu'il fallait all un
psychologue est-ce qu'à votre avis ces
images doivent être montrées avec un
médecin scolaire ou en tout cas dans le
cadre de la médecine scolaire ou je dis
pas telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais
telle qu'elle pourrait être ou telle
qu'elle devrait être c'est ma première
question et ma deuxième question euh
quel est à votre avis le rôle des
parents et comment
euh euh comment comment sensibiliser
informer les parents par rapport à ces
images
à à la façon dont dont ces choses sont
traitées mais surtout pour les
alerter sur des signes qui pourraient
laisser penser que leur enfant consomme
ou dil enfin que leur enfant a des liens
avec le narcotrafic d'une façon ou d'une
autre est-ce que en guyan vous avez
participé à ce genre de choses ou
pensez-vous avec votre expérience que ce
serait des choses à mettre en place
et puis je vais poser la question on va
peut-être demander à Monsieur califé de
de de poser sa question oui merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur le
Maire de votre témoignage ma question
ressemble à celle de de ma ma collègue
on sait que c'est une plateforme c'est
pas quelle est quelle est l'importance
de la consommation locale et si c'est le
cas si elle est importante est-ce que
vous avez des moyens de lutte de
prévention vous l'avez vous l'avez
évoqué et les répercussions sur les
hospitalisations dans ces
cas écoutez là je n'ai pas de pasz de
chiffres hein parce que je je je je l'ai
vécu et de temps en temps bon j'en parle
avec avec des collègues qui sont encore
sur le terrain
euh nous sommes quand même dans une
situation très grave parce que la drogue
elle est devenue banale et c'est parce
que elle est devenue banale s util
qu'on pourrait euh mettre cette
sensibilisation euh au niveau
scolaire mais je dirais quand je le dis
c'est sensibilisé très tôt très tôt euh
par des
fois
euh sur la situation comment ça peut
devenir et cetera
et je pense que nous vivons dans une
société qui est fragile parce que bon
médecin vous dit il faut faire attention
que je peux comprendre mais je crois
est-ce que en allant entre
guillemets brutalement on tout on prend
la précaution parce que nous on
préparait quand
même les élèves à aux images qu'il av vu
il y en a quand même pas mal qui
tournent de l'œil et après la psycholog
éit
là qui est et CER et cetera je pense
qu'on devrait breire l'expérience parce
que
euh dernièrement il y a eu je crois que
c'est au il y a une mère de famille qui
n'avit pas hésité à impliquer ses
enfants dans euh dans le trafic de
drogue euh je crois qu'elle a pris 7 ans
de prison quand même
euh ce qui veut dire que ça arrive ça
arrive et moi j'ai voyagé une fois avec
un jeune la méthode utilisé pour le
détecter était simple comme bas comme
cétait banal le jeune est arrivé devant
le poste de police le policier lui a
demandé vous allez où il savait même pas
qu'il allait en France il était en train
d'citer il avait pas la il avait pas la
réponse vous allez faire quoi euh puce
que le poli dit vous allez en France oui
monsieur euh vous allez faire quoi il
sait pas vous allez en stage oui
monsieur je vous cache pas que j'ai été
curieux et ils ont interpelé trois ou
quatre dans l'avion dans ce jeunne ça
veut dire que quelque part il y a un
travail de sensibilisation à faire parce
que ils sont à mon avis ils sont
facilement repérables du fait de leur
naïveté et du de la page de G maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il faut impliquer la
médecine dans dans dans dans
sensibilisation mais en tout cas je je
je maintiens que ce sera aussi une façon
de faire comme on le fait avec la
sécurité routière au niveau de de de la
drogue et la situation est suffisamment
grave pour qu'on puisse
pas
tenter quelque chose vous avez le
principe en étant un peu large sur le
100 % contrôle en guyen qui est contesté
par certains ben tout simplement parce
que à mon avis il serait intéressant de
démontrer par A + B le 100 % contrôle à
peut-être ses failles c'est sûr ça je
n'en doute pas hein je suis sûr que
qu'il a des failles mais en tout cas
démontrer que ça a permis d'interpeller
même si c'est trois personnes euh ben
c'est trois personnes qui sont
interpellées qui ne pourront pas qui
vont qui sont sanctionnés pour le trafic
de drogues moi dans ma commune je vous
cache pas que bon j'ai l'œil dessus mais
euh c'està-dire que je ne peux rien
faire de particulier parce que bon euh M
mon éant au PJ je pense que ça a quand
même des limites et on sait le danger
que ça peut avoir si on n'est pas euh
entouré de je dirais euh de structure
pour vous permettre justement de de
réunir les jeunes pour leur faire de la
sensibilisation au trafic de
St merci est-ce que Monsieur Jérémy
souhaite répondre à ces deux questions
la première sur l'école la deuxième sur
la consommation locale oui enfin mais
j'aurais bien enfin je pensais que
j'aurais aussi à répondre au au
questions sur au questionnair donc bien
sûr bien sûr à toute hein ouii bien sûr
voà euh en fait pour pour avoir
peut-être une vision parallèle par
rapport à mon collègue dravador euh
quand quand vous avez vous avez posé
quels sont les effets concrets du
narcotrafic notamment dans les
évolutions ben chez moi il y a pour moi
il y a il y a il y a la vision à voir
comme il disait avant le 100% contrôle
euh et et le le 100% contrôle a modifié
considérablement même l'évolution même
qu'on constate dans nos propres communes
avant avant avant le 100 % contrôle euh
la drite pouvait pas circuler assez
aisément euh via la Guyane hein il y a
on disit on parlait d'une vingtaine de
enfin de de mules par par vol euh et
donc c'était au départ c'était
effectivement dir que c'était un moyen
de pour la famille de vivre hein c'est
ça touchit davantage l'Ouest gu anè le r
du Maroni et de plus en plus on a vu on
a vu que ça se généralisait même les
enfants de médecins enfin on a eu des
enfants de cadre qui qui s'adonnait à ce
type de de business donc ça
effectivement ça florissait et et et
vraiment euh la l'ppareis du 100 %
contrôle a eu à mis un frein moi j'ai
l'occasion de discuter avec euh des
jeunes de ma commune qui euh qui me
l'ont dit très clairement enfin bon on
les voyait qu' circulait avant il il
pouvit passer aisément et donc
l'évolution sur la population à l'époque
bon il y avait de la dscolarisation euh
les avant le 100% contrôle les jeunes
pensaient que la vie était facile il
suffisait de faire un voyage en
franceonal pour avoir 5000 10000 € donc
c'était c'était la belle vie et depuis
le 100 % contrôle euh c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué pour eux ils vous disent
que c'est compliqué pour eux et il y a
vraiment bah ce refoulement qui se fait
euh au niveau de l'aéroport et donc euh
montre une certaine un nouveau une
nouvelle relation un certain rapport
avec avec ce ce trafic donc d'une part
les jeunes euh sont beaucoup plus
prileux à à partir et tout dans mon disc
mon propre liiminaire pardon je dit il
faut qu'on pense à la réinsertion parce
que des jeunes qui étaient dans le
trafic qui sont toujours harcelé par
leur par leur tête de réseau pour pour y
aller pour rentrer dans le dispositif
pour aller faire encore la mulle ces
jeunes savent qu'ils ne pouront pas
passer ils ont très peu de chance par
rapport avant par rapport au dispositifs
son sans contrôle donc qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il se font ben l'autre jour
par exemple un jeune de chez moi s'est
fait
tabasser on pense que c'est sur c'est
son fond de règlement de compte parce
qu'il n'a pas pu ou bien parce qu'il n'a
pas pu partir ou qu' n'a pas voulu
partir donc il a S fait tavasser il y a
dû heureusement qu' l'intervention de
voisin pour que pour qu'il ne soit
peut-être pas alors je pense pas qu'il
vousz tuer mais vraiment lu donner une
correction donc du coup ce qu'on voit on
voit cette prure inquiétude de des
jeunes qui avant qui faisait à partir et
et nous en fait les je dis que les mèes
aussi les les mèes nous sommes pas les
les premiers mais nous venons nous
devenons un Maon important de de de cela
en fait parce que les jeunes bon
certains vous disent carrément
maintenant ne peux plus je ne peux plus
est-ce que vous pouvez m'aider à parce
que je sais que ma famille ma famille
peut être en danger donc
systématiquement je signale ça à la
gendarmerie on essaie de de trouver des
de partenaires donc vraiment pour pour
l'alguman euh le le dispositif a marqué
une enfin un coup d'arrêt cert et une
autre approche par rapport à à cette à
cette relation
les les les trafic sont toujours là bien
sûr sont toujours là sont toujours
présents sont toujours son son son rôun
peu partout et et bien sûr là on trouve
on trouve maintenant une violence
intradépartementale c'està-dire que le
jeune qui n'a pas pu partir via le par
rapport au dispositif se retrouve
harcelé la famille ce les familles
certaines famemilles sont menacées sont
menacé ou on menace le jeunes de de s
prendre à sa famille à ses petits frères
donc il y a une autre approche donc
c'est vrai que le dispositif pe très
pertinent mais quelque part le
dispositif contraint contraint le les
les mules en fait les trafiquants AR
Guan
et pour peut-être à terme ça peut avoir
une explosion une de la violence mais
lié à ce trafic de drog en fait voilà et
ensuite
également enfin le le fait il y avait il
y avait le le PCR le poste de contrôle
routierakubo qui est allé vers Saint
vers Margot aussi ça a beaucoup modifié
l'approche donc du coup euh ça permet de
de concentrer canalyser enfin je sais
pas qu'expressloyé sur sur Saint-Laurent
le dispositif Margo est très très
opérationnel et très opérant même en
terme de résultat par rapport à à
sonplement initiale et donc vraiment ça
ça concentre le trafic aussi beaucoup de
TR trfic dans dans l'anis donc ceux pour
lesquels on on doit on doit s'en
inquiéter donc voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire par rapport au première
question par rapport à par rapport à
l'école oui je je partage il faut
effectivement il faut oui il faut faire
de la prévention je dire la prévention
il faut vraimentire la prévention on a
par de psychologue alors moi je
franchement je n'ai pas de la RET typ
mais il faut penser à la prévention euh
car en discutant avec les jeunes enfin
les jeunes qui regardent aussi la télé
pour ça c'est facile ça devient facile
maintenant fait façon si je travaille je
moi je suis moi je suis chez
établissement d'un établissement
scolaire euh aussi donc qu' AC les
jeunes pour eux c'est tellement facile
d'avoir de l'argent via être être
trafiquant être mul euh faire de faire
du trafic de de de cannabis
effectivement moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire la prévention dès le plus
jeune âge moi de de LCO maternel car
souvent C ces jeunes ces jeunes qui font
la muule au départ c'était vraiment pour
aider les parents je dis avant
maintenant avant avant c'était ça
maintenant ça vulgarisé c'était pour
aider les parents donc les peut-être que
certains parents de chez nous ont
bénéficie on bénéficié de la de la rente
financière du trafic de drogue donc pour
eux les enfants beaucoup pour les donc
ils ont vu leurs frères leurs grands
frères faire arrivver avec des les
parents qui sont des parents des
familles indigentes il VO le frère
arriver avec comme il disit avec des
voitures neuves ou avec des des chemises
course enfin bon bref des des des
vêtements vraiment de de haut niveau et
et quelque part enfin dans on voit que
ces jeunes ont quasiment intégré ce
dispositif mais qui est lié aussi comme
je dis à la pauvreté de la Guen 53 % à
14 % de chômage 14 15 % de chômage donc
pour en fait la la la solution la plus
simple c'est de c'est de c'est de faire
la Mle donc voilà je sais pas s av
d'autres questions sur lesquelles je
devais répondre ou
regarde je
lisais et puis voilà donc je vous disais
par rapport à pour moi en fait l'accent
qu'on doit mettre c'est beaucoup sur la
réinsertion et comment protéger
finalement ces ces personnes par rapport
au dispositif son sur contrôle ces
personnes qui se retrouvent euh qui se
roule à l'aéroport qui ont géré alors
c'est pour beaucoup qui ont géré de la
drogue alors qui doivent bien sûr les
les enlever qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent dire qu'est-ce
qu'ils doivent dire pardon à
commanditaire euh et comment nous on
peut les protéger en fait comment nous
les protéger pour éviter qu'il se fasse
alors pere pas chaque fois qui se fe qui
se fasse passer à
tabac moi ça moi en fait c'était c'est
vraiment la la question à laquelle je je
pose le dispositif fonctionne fonctionne
mais que fait-on des jeunes qui n'ont
pas pu passer et qui ont qui ont
toujours le produit qui ont toujours qui
garde toujours le produit donc
voilà merci Monsieur alors je crois qu'
une question de d'Olivier
cadiic merci monsieur le Président euh
oui dans dans le développement du trafic
on nous a signalé la la présence de
faction brésilienne en prison à Cayenne
est-ce que cela ne serait pas ne
pourrait pas expliquer le fait que
justement des jeunes ressortent de
prison comme s'ils avaient été recrutés
c'est ce qu'on on peut observer par
exemple pour le
terrorisme à la différence des anti vous
avez une frontière terrestre difficile à
contrôler euh une une audition
précédente parlait de manaous comme
plaque tournante de la drog qui arrivait
de Colombie du Pérou euh est-ce que la
porosité de la frontière avec le Brésil
ne justement ne facilite pas le le
trafic et quelles sont vos observations
sur les trafics venant du Brésil ce qui
est ce que vous pourriez préconiser et
je vis être sûr que quand vous parlez du
Surinam euh est-ce que vous parlez bien
des des systèmes de rayon X qui
permettent de détecter la drogue dans
les aéroports pour scanner tous les
passagers puisque c'est on a parlé de ça
dans une audition et je vis être sûr que
c'est c'est bien ce système dont il
dispose au Surinam qui pourrait mériter
justement une évolution législative pour
qu'on puisse l'imposer merci Monsieur
les maire
oui
y cè vas-y non c'est mon collègue Jérém
ou c'est à moi lequel des deux allez-y
choisissez monsieur labrador
allez-y bon alors alors c'est que bon
vous
savez nous sommes des voisins le Surinam
le Brésil alors je pense
qu'effectivement l'appareil qui
détecte la drogue à l'intérieur sur a
beaucoup fait diminu le le trafic hein
j'ai discuté avec un
un un ami euh du suram on parlait de ça
il me disait que on nous a fait comment
on dit en rugby une passe en retrait
quoi parce que là c'est vraiment je
crois que c'est le c'est la façon la
plus efficace à mon avis à prend Bua de
euh de réduire voire d'annuler le le
trafic de drogue euh en Guan parce que
suram ils ont mis ils ont mis les moyens
puis c'est réglé enfin son réglé bon
mais en tout cas euh on a quand même
récupérer le trafic je veux dire parce
que bon le 100 % contrôle c'est une très
bonne chose parce que je quand je pars
souvent il y a pas la tête du client
tout le monde y passe et c'est une très
bonne chose
maintenant il y a des loup mais je pense
que alors avec le Brésil je connais pas
trop euh je dire parce que maintenant on
a une nouvelle la voie aérienne euh qui
qui euh qui est ouverte là maintenant
sur alors je pense que par bateau ça
doit se faire hein c'est pas ce n'est
pas une nouveauté mais
euh faudrait peut-être même le même
moyen euh il faut garder aussi le 100 %
contrôle euh pour le Brésil pareil que
qu'on le fait sur la métropole à mon
avis il faudit aussi le faire pareil
parce que j'ai vu sauf erreur ou
peut-être allègement du du du dispositif
j'ai vu de fois où lorsquil y avait le
vol du Brésil euh on contrôlait le vol
vers vers l'Hexagone mais pas sur le
Brésil estce que un système qui a été
mis en place je sais rien ou alors ce
jour-là c'était particulier ça je mais
c'est à voir mais je pense qu'il faut
faire le contrôle sur tous les
voles merci Monsieur Jérémy et puis on
conclura après euh alors alors
certainement il y a il y a des
recrutements qui se qui se font qui se
font en prisant alors c'est pas
seulement côté brésilien mais côté côté
Surinam il y a aussi il y a aussi la la
le Surinam aussi qui qui est unvo
ailleur et à l'époque du Surinam par
rapport l'ancien président bouters qui
était bon qui a été encore qui é
aujourd'hui condamné pour 20 an de
prisons qui était qui était entre
guillemets d' trafic de drogue donc
c'est vraiment ça ça facilitait
l'émergence même le trafic entre entre
via le Surinam et le Brésil a toujour
été une plaque tournante donc pour moi
euh nos frontières sont pouruses elles
ne seront pas
resturont toujours mais je crois que euh
il faut se mettre en comm pe dis mon
collègue au même niveau que nos pays
voisins en fait c'est vrai que on
constate un
coup coup d'arrêt à l'aéroport du du
Surinam enfin bon même au Guyana même au
guyz gu paril pare he quand c'est pareil
il y a il y a les les contrôles sont
très rigoureux alors peut-être qu' sont
qui respectent pas forcément les normes
qui sont qui qui doivent être appliqué
par rapport à la législation française
VO européenne mais c'est vrai que nous
sommes dans un dans un territoire
sudamazonien je pense que nous devons
apporter des réponses
sudamazonienes via nos VI nos voisins
euh également en terme de coopération à
renforcer bien sûr la la la coopération
entre entre les deux les deux pays nous
avons ça bien sûr que il y a c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué c'est c'est
peut-être une démarche qui est qui est
faite he qui est qui qui est pertinente
mais qui reste compliquée pour pour la
France car ces paysl aussi vivent de de
de de C trafique vous disiez en fait il
y a il y a un de vos collègues qui pense
qui posait la question quel est la masse
en fait la masse le flux financier en
guyen je suis pas certain qui est
vraiment en je je parle vraiment je pas
pas il y a un gros flux financier la GU
c'est juste un transit pour euh pour que
la drogue arrive en Europe donc reste un
transit et cela profite davantage au
pays aux pays qui envoi donc Brésil
Surinam euh parce qu'en gu il ils vont
recruter souvent des mules en mis les
gros coups qu'ils vont faire qu'on avait
vu à au port au port de commerce avec un
un technicien qui avait qui avait pris
400 kg mais mais
je suis pas certain sincèrement que
après le compléter qu'il y a un gros
flux financier en Guyane la guyan reste
un transit un transit c'est c'est
vraiment la GU le système beaucoup de
jeunes une forte
démographie% la à moins de 25 ans donc
forcément comprend ça peut être un
marché pour eux donc ça reste un trafic
làdessus et je dis vraiment pour moi la
réponse aussi doit
être sudamazonen alors c'est qu'il a un
cadre euh pour nous permettre de mettre
un un sérieux fre un coup d'arrêt sur
sur ce
trafic merci messieur je pense qu'on va
en rester là pour tenir nos horaires
sauf si Monsieur labrador va rajouter
quelque chose évidemment bien sûr
monsieur Laabad oui je je confirme ce
que dit mon collègue Jérémy euh c'est
vrai que alors à mon avis et comme il
dit euh il do avoir un transfert qui se
fait de de font ailleurs parce que ici
quand quelqu'un est dans le trafic vous
le récupérez rapid enfin vous le repérez
rapidement parce que son train de vie
change donc ça de vu et peut-être qu'il
ils se sont rendu compte et peut-être
qu'ils font différemment mais ce que dit
mon collègue n'est pas
faux merci écoutez nous vous adressons
nos sincères remerciement pour votre
participation nous excusons pour ce
petit retard à l'allumage ça marche
mieux à courou que qu'ici vis
et on vous souhaite une bonne
journée et encore merci pour votre
participation au
revoir